what's the hardest position to play in
baseball I would say pitcher pitcher I
don't know how they do it I'm a busted
up first baseman that's the easiest
position first base cuz everything's
coming at you oh pitcher by far pitcher
pitcher catcher hardest position to play
in baseball without a doubt it's the
manager catcher I was going to say
catcher if you do your job you just did
your job and if you don't people get mad
at you it's pitcher obviously got to be
pitcher game's in your hand catcher you
got to catch the Heat and you got to
block it and you got to throw people out
back up catcher cuz you're on the off
court all the time 100%